If you go to Vimeo.com
staff picks page,
you'll find several short films that
play in the same meticulously designed
weird art house thriller space.
As Jonathan glazers under the skin.
You see that kind of thing on the web
more than you do in the theater because
supreme ambiguity as a cinematic
category rarely attracts investment.
The reason for this is contemptible,
but obvious,
the lack of explanation or closure is
painful.
It hurts,
as m John Harrison says,
therapists and unwillingness to serve up
that failure to film goers,
that pain,
that anxiety has ruled Hollywood from
the start.
So ideas like these find a home on the
web which embraces everything.
Art,
how shorts are potent because there are
brief 20 minutes at the very longest,
happy to contain a single question to be
a single question.
What makes under the skin so special is
that it maintains the same potency
across 108 minutes.
The movie follows scarlet Johansen as
Laura a blank face,
but beautiful alien as she follows and
ensnares young men who are never to be
seen or heard from.
Again,
watching listlessly at the beach as a
couple and their dog drowned in a strong
undertow.
It's made clear that Laura does not
possess a traditional set of morals,
if any,
at all.
A few compatriot aliens with speed bikes
act as a cleanup crew for her nocturnal
activities and make sure she keeps on
schedule.
Plot wise,
that's pretty much it.
The interactions between Laura and her
victims are tense and gripping in
between.
Glazer treats us to long carefully frame
takes of pedestrians at shopping centers
or Johansen's face filmmakers.
Hold on images so you can examine them.
If you see this film in theaters,
be sure to let your eyes wander.
I was struck by the depth of the
Scottish landscapes,
the camera always sure to have elements
in the for middle and background,
more three dimensional than anything you
need glasses for,
particularly when contrasted with the
surreptitious camera work,
glazer use to capture real Scott's from
the window of Laura's nondescript white
van pepper throughout his imagery of a
more surreal for variety,
evoking Kubrick at times mostly in its
boldness and not as much as the trailer
suggests strung together by the perfect
screening score of Nica Levitt.
Then toward the end of the film,
Laura's inhumanity begins to peel back
just in time for humanity to show its
darkest side.
We finally glimpse what's under the
skin,
but as she or it an alien,
the Michel novel on which under the skin
is based says so even glaser who's
adaptation runs far afield of the source
material has said explicitly that
Johansen's character is other worldly
taking the film as it is.
However,
I'm not so sure there is no question
that Laura is alien and all that
adjective means unfamiliar,
disturbing,
distasteful.
It's impossible to parse or motivations
except for in the broadest strokes here
to the novel goes into much,
much more detail,
but I'm wary to identify anything that
the film itself doesn't choose to.
Maybe Laura is just the demonstration of
a feeling,
an embodiment of all in nature that is
reminisce,
but disinterested or just the idea of
disinterest set loose in the locks and
undertows of human yearning.
Even this I'm afraid is saying too much
art.
House movies are unapologetic in their
use of cinemas.
Unique toolbox as a medium of light and
sound of imagery.
Film is an innately ambiguous language.
Filmmakers like laser,
no doubt express their vision in this
form because actual language wasn't up
to their task.
Why then should we try to bring movies
like under the skin,
back to the page?
It works so hard to transcend because
the alternative is paint that vast
ambiguous space like a dark,
empty room where you can be ensnared by
something evocative,
ensnared and suddenly consumed.
Never learning why.